asking for a man who's in the top 10
percent of men
[Music]
you don't qualify for one
and you're making I mean I don't I don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's
an average guy
what is she doing
I think she's reading the comments oh so
it's kind of like minor here
I want to figure out how to get them on
the screen blessing us to help me I
don't know how to do it sometimes yeah
blessing I feel like
um
oh
in order to fully submit I have to feel
like he's in well then you're gonna then
you're gonna die alone how about that
all right let me just cut to the chase
man uh you can feel like what you want
to but women like you die alone
straight up because you think you're
better than the men that you qualify for
and the only reason honestly ma'am that
I can see a woman like yourself really
thinking you deserve more is because you
earn more because you earn more money
than most people around you in North
Carolina say something that I don't know
it's just like in my head when he says
die alone everyone naturally dies alone
but I feel like what he like meant to
say was like you're gonna die without
being loved the way you want to like
you're not gonna get what you want
without a family right because when you
think about it the decision to not have
a family it's like even if you choose to
like break up your heart like families
are so different yes when it's like
around the people that love you know
it's just so different with versus like
you know by yourself
for sure but no I think you're women do
you are you a big family person
New York
women usually do die alone though yes
that's true yeah we usually do
then we date older so it's like a double
win you know my dad told me I think I
said this yesterday he's like you can't
date I had a ex-boyfriend yes very
successful man who's a bit overweight
all right and my dad's like you can't do
that like you try to take the other guy
even if he's got less money but not fat
and he was just like because you're
gonna have to take care of him and deal
with all his health issues and I was
like
one more go for the reaction oh yeah you
could bring her in
trouble
is she coming oh she's going again
if your ass worked at the post office
you would not think so highly of your
opportunities
and that's the reality we don't men
don't care about your money
not the kind of man that you want we
it ain't ours and we care about the fact
that you are older and you got kids
and your average
and your reality of your life has showed
you that
you don't have the kind of meaning that
you want no come on oh no you're good
come on in come on in welcome how was
your date it was cute I guess it was
cute or you were you treated like a
queen not really
[Laughter]
would you go on a second date maybe not
no you know
I'm all right
you friend zone did they interview you
after about it no we haven't done that
oh okay I think they're going too late
here's your headphones thank you are you
aware of who Kevin Samuels is oh the one
yes yeah have you seen his content you
can scoot him a little bit if it's tight
it's gonna drag me off this yeah that's
right I don't know how to okay well
hopefully that works
um oh wait I need to I need to read the
supers
um a lot of people call my followers
broke we don't have no broke
oh no no no no no Alvin she showed up at
a steakhouse but wants to but wants
Sushi send the asteroid send the
asteroid talking about that girl
um Charlie Brown Charlie it looks like
we're gonna be best friends you know how
to make shaloff rice Pearl I do major
props unemployed I'm a small business
owner and I have a ft job put some
respect down our names I know they just
say it's a bunch of men just whining I'm
like the amount of one-on-ones I've had
with guys that make over 100k is kind of
crazy so they all need to pipe down
let's put some respect on the jpt gang's
name also
also I really want to set people up I
really want to help you know facilitate
a community World we're all having fun a
lot of Pals and we're gonna do boxing if
you want to see me box some crazy people
smoke someone
I I have to find a good opponent that's
in the ring I want to wow it has to be
someone the girls that have asked me to
box they're like for my London hate
group but they they're not they're not
famous enough that's the only problems
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the girl dating blueface yeah I
would I would I actually feel like I'd
get along with her but you know
I I feel like I could I'm I'm an athlete
you know what I mean I'm an athlete
that's why women lie they're thinking
nah
I'm being polite
okay so she called into a show for
dating advice okay we're so we're
towards the end but I'm gonna just you
know come on your door trying to find
you
see what we've done in this country this
world is we've told women like yourself
that you can have it all and you got a
prince charming who's six foot
six feet tall six figure income jawline
all this other kind of stuff and I'm
sorry man no
most people get average people
especially average people
and you're an average person I mean
let's be real you're not well she's got
thoughts I want to hear your thoughts
she's like oh my God to be called
average I feel like that's like less
than being called ugly really like
that's just like so you're just like
because you can be ugly but with the
personality but to be called like
average it's just like you're just
I wonder why that is because most people
are average
I don't know there's like people who do
like certain stuff and then there's
people who just like live everyday lives
but like they're happy with that like
that's their little bubble so it's just
like cool
what does she do like I don't know I
haven't seen what she does yeah it's
just like most people have normal jobs
most people do average things you know I
I just don't know I feel like as women
we're all delusional because we all
think we're special delusions sometimes
can work in your favor though I agree I
was delusional to start this thing
and it worked out but I would say most
I've seen I've met a lot of delusional
women over the past year and a half I
think if you're delusional and can't
back it up then it's like the bad type
of delusional but if you can walk the
walk and talk the talk then okay I like
the delusion line I remember I used to
tell everyone at school like I'm gonna
be out here interviewing big big
celebrities one day my first ever like
red cop interview interview Brad Pitt
delusional oh shut up you want to read
Brett hold on that's my life how did how
did that happen so I literally there was
this guy on Instagram and like he used
to put adverts to do like premieres and
things like that and I must have
messaged him and I didn't get that job
and then like the night before he calls
me like something they was like hey do
you want to do bullet train like red
carpet I was like I'm constantly in
everything like yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes and he kind of told me like listen
we're at the end of the carpet you're
probably not going to be able to talk to
like the big big people so don't like
have your expectations I said I'm just
happy to be here
and then like yeah Brad Pitt can I see
you got a video I know you got a video
on it do I have a video
I read Taylor Johnson literally like the
video of me and irritated Johnson
literally got like a mill views on my
Tick Tock well while you find it I'm
gonna read these supers real quick read
these supers hold on one second guys
again email list events sign up keep
modern women accountable accountable
keep hitting people with reality praying
for you to pair up with a good man and
have a large family the center of my
world I'm broke okay well you didn't
have to you didn't have to say that okay
um Chief Keef Pearl we ain't broke I'm
fit 100k with benefit stocks all
together not just not six foot these
haters can put some respect on
just ignore us
um I like to watch Pearl all YouTubers
that have members page to sign up for
their option there's a page next to
their name but for some reason there's
no option next to your YouTube page I'm
gonna screenshot that because I actually
don't
I don't know how to do you got to fix
that big fan thank you again the Super
Chat thanks for showing them we're not
all brokies except apparently except
apparently um the center of my world who
said he is broke so yeah
um okay let's see should I hold out
and if you can see the reflection I
don't know if it's gonna load below
because you know the YouTubers
but you can see him then yeah that's so
cool and like he was so like he's so hot
in real life really he's a very very
defensive man would you ask him I was
asking him like what's about the movie
no I think I was asking what's his
favorite thing about London is and like
if he would take something from like
what he would take from Japan and put in
yeah that's the direct like producers
and they director
so how old are you I'm 21. 21. so you
are attracted to 40 something year old
men I mean
the girl on the thing was saying that
young girls don't like older men no like
I can find him physically attractive but
if he wanted to date me I know how to
find that weird I'd be like yo
[Music]
Microsoft you got you had a pet grooming
business
oh
you've been making six figures for the
last three years
okay
oh she looks upset and she is but if I'm
looking at you but if I looked at you
and I took all that off of you all the
eyelashes and all the hair what do you
look like under there oh I mean I look
the same man just no you don't because
if you did you wouldn't have all that
you don't I'm sorry no you don't you
don't look the same because if you did
you wouldn't have all that on
so what is your advice for uh all right
I'll tell you my advice man because
you're not listening to me this is why I
always recommend you need the United
States therapy cool people think most of
us in black community need therapy but
you're not you're not dealing with
reality
I asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me
but it doesn't sound like you're too
proud of him
how's it what kind of student is your
child
he's a excellent does he have any
behavioral problems no he actually got a
YouTube channel and he's trying I don't
need that I don't need no no no but
where is it but his daddy is still if
his daddy is alive does he have a
relationship with his father
yeah he does
then what's your issue with him
um he's not um business minded like my
father and my uncle and then why did you
choose to make a baby with him before
you got married
what are you thinking you think you you
what do you think about this exchange I
can see the point he's trying to make
but at the same time we don't know the
situation a lot of people have babies
out of wedlock depending on their
beliefs you know what I'm saying like
some people don't necessarily believe in
abortion so she might have had the baby
because she didn't want to get rid of it
but as well I don't like when men kind
of put the blame on the woman when it's
a lot of the time like dads are leaving
the household like that's not
necessarily because before we know their
relationship could have been flopped off
like and like it was better it's better
to live in I feel like a separated happy
home than a two-parent household where
it's fighting because that's just as
worse I I think that the outcome of the
family is most of the time 100 the
woman's fault
yeah
I think because you know when you're
ovulating
I I just think it's under it's your
responsibility to make sure that the guy
that you procreate with is a good man
yes if you don't have good Role Models
around you it's your job to go find some
and get their advice yeah and I think
that if you make a baby with someone
that isn't a good man that's your own
fault and I think it says something
about you that you don't make decisions
well it does take I do feel like people
should take responsibility for
themselves in that respect like that 100
agree because then it's like if you knew
he was a bad guy and you still went
there then it's just like you knew the
outcome but let's like let's be like
like say if you like having a baby with
Nick Cannon not to like business but
like you know your child is not gonna
get special special attention and so I
was like I can feel your pain but at the
same time kind of useful is it really
yeah it takes two to make a baby but
yeah if you can see the red flags try
and avoid it but so why don't why do you
not like blaming women when it is our
fault because I think at the same time
like when emotions come into things it
can like blind your logic so some women
like it's like when people stay in
abusive relationships it's like someone
who's never been in that situation can
of course be like why don't you just
leave why don't you just leave but it's
like you're so emotionally that's why I
think therapy is good but then I know a
lot of people can afford therapy or
don't actually know
what's going on yeah so it can get a bit
see I I still think as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible